yeah well it's so hard to get a movie
created Created into the Finish Line
especially these days it seems even
harder dude especially comedies nowadays
you have to like mask it this is why
it's a big action comedy because you
really have to go like action action and
then and then it's a comedy but this we
we it's just like it's it's why I was so
happy to work with Sanders company is we
could just go Full Steam on the comedy
as opposed to you know you watch
comedies nowadays and you're like
no this isn't a [__] comedy you're
not where's the jokes like where's the
Bits bad yeah comedy's gotten kind of
bad huh yeah it kind of sucks yeah movie
comedy movie com yeah there's still good
shows and stuff but like yeah movie
comedy uh it's it's hard but luckily uh
I I my theory is I think
I think like Marvel ruined it I feel
like superhero movies kind of ruined
comedies because they people watch you
go to the theater yeah and you expect to
watch something that costs 200 million
dollars to make in comedy movies aren't
that aren't that so you're like well why
would I spend the same amount of money
to go watch a little comedy in the
theater
if I could spend the same amount of
money and go see something that is is
worth 200 million dollars right you know
and then they still make those movies
kind of funny like they're I mean
they're not comedies but there's like
right there's ants they're like oh my
God is that raccoon talking yeah this is
hilarious
which it is but uh but yeah so it's not
it's not like a real comedy and then now
they there used to be something like
every Studio would put out several
comedies every every year and there was
like 45 or 46 comedies in the theaters
every year so about every week or every
other week or so there's a new comedy in
the theaters and uh and then now last
year there was like six or seven
crazy crazy and people need and the
crazy thing is is it feels like people
need comedy more than ever yeah I feel
like they want it I feel yeah so that's
what this movie was it was like and
there's no like hidden message I feel
like nowadays
people like you get to the end of what
you think is a comedy and you're like is
that about global warming yeah yeah
you're like is this is just like some
deep hidden message that I'm supposed to
I'm supposed to recycle more or like you
know yeah there has to be something else
right oh the Moon is trans is that what
yeah is that the surprising yeah you're
like okay I guess we do have to think
about that don't we
yeah I agree there's there's a lot of
what was that was a great and that's
what your David Spade and your movie is
about is yeah trans Moon yeah
you guys are just the people to to
spread that message oh it's about
Transportation it's about a lot of
vehicles admitting who they really are
the cars wanting to be motorcycles
motorcycles wishing they were scooters
yeah it's just it's where things are man
oh dude there's a riveting scene where a
short bus uh admits that he's a
skateboard yeah
and it's yeah it's powerful whoa
but the great thing is I feel like you
could walk into a place and pitch that
and then yeah and they wouldn't laugh
you out of the room they'd be like okay
well that's the thing you know because I
like my job now is kind of well
obviously acting and that kind of stuff
but then like I'm pitching a lot so I'll
like pitch movies uh and every executive
is like yeah but why should we make this
movie now and you're like because it's
funny yeah because it's funny [__] what
do you mean like whatever happened to
just like we want to make people laugh
like it doesn't need to be right yeah
right there it doesn't need to attach
itself to some like hook in the world
right now it doesn't I mean if it does
and that's the movie then sure right but
it doesn't always have to it could just
be like whatever happened to just it's
funny for funny sake I know I feel like
super bad was one of the last movies
that they kind of had like that in some
ways like that was really just super
funny like I mean there's been a lot of
other funny movies I'm not saying that
um yeah but I get what you're saying it
was like The Hangover super bad it was
like that was sort of the last gasp of
like for no reason at all like this is
just [__] funny because it's funny
you know and luckily like Netflix is one
of the places that is just willing to
roll the dice a little more than than
other places because it matters
so much less like like like the machine
and Sebastian's movie um about my father
I think uh the fact that they put both
of those movies out on the same weekend
I'm like that [__] sucks because like
you're putting out six movies all year
long and then you put two of them out on
the same weekend and so like if you're
gonna go see a comedy you had to choose
between these two and then when those
movies only make eight million dollars
or whatever opening weekend well you're
like well if it was only the one movie
maybe could have made 14. could have
made yeah 15 16 and then that's a
healthy amount for it to make but right
yeah so uh
so yeah support if you like comedy
support comedies watch it tell your
friends to watch it
um and then and then we'll have the
opportunity to make more of them and and
it used to be you know well people were
like well if you you made better
comedies then and it's like sure but
it's hard to make a movie first of all
it's really hard and secondly uh there
used to be like 40 shots and making a
good comedy and then if maybe two or
three of them
were classic comedy and you're like
well that old school and came out you're
like well there was 28 other movies that
weren't old school that came out that
year you know what I mean right so the
more opportunities we have to make
classic comedies the the more we'll be
able to to nail it but I I do think
Outlaws uh has a potential to be one of
those type of movies so I'm really proud
of it hope you enjoyed that video and
you can watch another and you can watch
this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy two options watch one this one or
this one